how you doing
hi good how are you i'm doing good uh
glad to see you in cyberspace um so
i'm curious when was the last time a
director told you
we really need you to get this in one
take i don't remember the last time
that that's happened i i yeah uh
i'm no i don't i don't remember i'm
trying to think of like some crazy
setup or stunt but yeah no i mean they
they
we're in the wall where you kind of have
to repeat repeat and repeat
so um most sets are pretty equipped for
that
i'm definitely curious uh when you first
saw jk simmons on set
and you saw the way he looked with the
beard uh were you just like well he
could just kill all the aliens on his
own what are we doing here
[Laughter]
yeah i i mean i didn't spend too much
time with him but
but yes he's definitely very capable
what do you think
would surprise people to learn about the
tomorrow war the making of the film
that perhaps they wouldn't know i mean i
think the making of the actual movie in
terms of the fight scenes
with the aliens themselves is quite
interesting i certainly found that to be
fascinating especially
partaking in all the different versions
in which we create the scene you know
where we
we fight um a prosthetic or or we do a
take with fighting
a guy in a in a unitard or then we do a
take with nothing at all
um so you know i just remember being
quite impressed with chris pratt and
you know these the aliens have these
tentacles and you know there was a take
that he did where he just was
completely pretending that you know he
had it there and i mean it was it's
amazing it's amazing
what we can pull off um with a film like
this
i think a lot of people don't realize
there's nothing there it's like
literally channeling your inner
eight-year-old
it kind of is it really is yeah uh so
you get to play a complete badass in
this movie uh
super smart super capable super tough
roles like this
are a little bit rare i'm just curious
how much you paid to be in the movie
i begged i begged you know the only way
they they would take me i had to sign up
for
you know multiple um other movies you
know
for free all for free i get it
oh one of the things that this is
originally going to be theatrical and
now it's coming out on amazon
and i think actually a lot more people
are going to watch it because it's going
to be on amazon
especially its release date you just
want to talk about uh premiering
streaming yeah i mean this is kind of a
whole new world but um
but it's definitely world that's taking
shape very fast
uh in in under the circumstances that
we're all in so i agree with you i think
there's going to be a lot more eyeballs
on it um
and especially for the states i mean
it's coming out you know right around
july 4th
um on the second and uh
it is definitely a great time for people
to be home and wanting to watch this
kind of a movie it's it's it's your big
summer
action blockbuster with a ton of
surprises in it
oh yeah that's actually something i
wanted to address which is this movie
pulls off the bad boys too
in that i thought the movie was over and
then i realized it's only the end of the
second act
there's a whole another chapter uh can
you sort of talk about that
yeah i you know it's surprising isn't it
um but
but that's you know that was one of the
draw cards for me is that there's this
whole other element of so you know that
really echoes
i think what we're facing as as people
in terms of
climate change i mean there's that
flavor that is added in there
at the end um where we kind of come full
circle and tie up the whole
the whole film um but yeah i mean
there's that there's there's a
surprising sort of um emotional
stuff in the film there's there's funny
i mean we have some really convenient
characters in there as well
that um that kind of take the pressure
off the intense
uh the intensity and the suspense that
you sit in on this on this
wild roller coaster ride of a film on
that note i gotta go
thank you so much i hope it's a huge hit
for you guys thank you very much thank
you